welcome everybody my name is Jessica
Weiss and on behalf of the council in
East Asian Studies National Committee on
us-china relations welcome to our
discussion of China and American
election we are on the cusp of election
day and in a campaign season where China
has figured perhaps more prominently
than ever before we're here today to
discuss what has been said what was
correct and what this might mean for you
as China relations i'm joined today by
three distinguished guests who've
traveled from various distances to be
with us here today first Erica Fowler
she's a professor at Wesleyan University
of the road and director of the Wesleyan
media project stephen roche here locally
a senior fellow at the jackson institute
and senior lecturer at the School of
Management and Jeremy whoo who's a
member of the committee of 100 and a
from senior advisor to the US Census
Bureau and one of the architects of the
report if you didn't pick up you might
want to get one on your way out looking
at perceptions of Chinese and of
Americans unfortunately due to Hurricane
sandy rescheduling this mint that Jim
fallows was unable to join us so
apologies but we're really happy to be
able to through thick and thin have
pulled this off anyway before we begin
I'd like to show a couple of clips first
from the presidential debate and then a
couple of congressional ads that have
been aired on China
china has been a currency years and
years and the president has a regular
opportunity to the label the Pacific as
a currency manipulator but refuses to do
so when he talks about getting tough on
China keep in mind that Governor Romney
invested in companies that were pioneers
of outsourced to China traditionally
been a sudden is there as attack since
then Hall of Fame she be in it Obama we
give a reduction to be gentle OC would
tell her what to do just like Hello see
sudden voted for the simians that spent
hundreds of billions in created jobs in
China cap and trade in American history
and we're expecting company that best
jobs overseas companies that send jobs
overseas all of any tax and fender betis
up on the river 63 Tyler Sutton
congressional leadership fund is
responsible for the content is
advertising the trade deficit with China
has moss United States almost three
million job for sure and brown is
calling for action against cheating in
China
take care because
his bill with horse trade and hostage it
creates and protect jobs by
I brought Democrats and Republicans
together to past eras of China now we
can level the playing field for American
workers I'm sure Brown that's why this
message so as you see this is not just a
matter of presidential rhetoric but
rhetoric by congressional candidates on
both sides of the aisle if the panelists
would join me up here look like to get
the discussion started
so why he is as Erica can you do with
some context for what we're seeing you
know how important are these in the
context of the larger campaign
advertising that we've seen this season
and are we seeing a difference from
previous elections well definitely I
think so um just in terms of context the
2010 was really the first time that we
saw China arise as a team in ads period
I mean we have data tracking back to
2000 and China really barely made a blip
on the radar prior to 2010 and in 2010
you said both parties coming up with
mentions of China and that's continued
in the presidential race this year we
are over a million ads aired in the
presidential cycle to date and that's
through October 29 so we're well over
that by now and about nine percent of
all of those to date have mentioned
China which is truly I think an
astonishing number almost nine percent
almost nine percent and and both parties
are using this in those thoughts as you
saw in the clips there I we we have a
code in our coding sheet for the
American flag and I kind of wish that
we've had one for the Chinese because it
is very very common you sod and one of
the clips there they were in in 2010 one
of my favorite ads that I used to
display what if the Chinese flag came
down at the very end of the clip and
said maybe this can't remember who it
was for somewhere in Pennsylvania and I
think it was like maybe so-and-so should
run for representative in China and the
trends I comes down so it's definitely a
theme as a prominent theme on both sides
the aisle both candidates are focusing
heavily on it um I think to date it's
about China's been Republic Mitt Romney
ads have been slightly more likely to
mention China than Obama ads but nearly
all of the outside interest group
earrings on the
side which is about half of all of Mitt
Romney's ads have mentioned in China so
that just sort of gives you the extent
to which it's being used and used
heavily um the most the most common way
in which you see China appearing tends
to be in ads that reference jobs and so
it's clearly a theme that is continuing
along the lines of outsourcing to China
like like you've heard in the clips
before that's the most prominent not all
of them are attack ads but a great
majority of them are and I think perhaps
the most interesting thing and this
happened in 2010 too is that you don't
just hear references of China in say the
Rust Belt states right that might be
sort of an expectation of where you
might hear that most commonly but it's
definitely not the case that they appear
only there it's there Ben mentions of
China in 88 markets this cycle in the
presidential race and not just the rust
belt so Albuquerque Boston Denver Las
Vegas all of those markets have seen
references to China so again it is it is
a real change from prior cycles hmm well
speaking of Romney's tough rhetoric on
China scheme I want to ask you what
would happen if on day one Romney
labeled China currency manipulator and
do you think he would do so are we
betting on him bluffing well I think
that's a fair point and actually I was
thinking about the fact that most of
these campaigns were used to having
politicians say one thing and then they
get elected and you know they especially
on China they move to the to the center
and personally I think
that is reckless and irresponsible and I
really believe that politicians need to
be held accountable for the statements
they make in the campaign and the
promises they make and you just heard
the the clip from one of the beta and
Romney says it every day on the campaign
trail and you know january twentieth you
know when he's elected and big if but
you know he'll take the oath of office
at twelve noon i'll go to the parade for
a few hours and then he'll go into the
Oval Office and the very first thing
you'll do is sign this executive order
so I said okay let's just fast
forwarding and give them credit for wing
and signing the order and then I wrote
up an op-ed piece in the FT said you
know what happens next and what happens
next any it's anybody's guess but it's
it's quite conceivable that in a tough
labor market and you know Erica I
mentioned the fact that China appears so
much in the context of discussions over
jobs the the China card is played
because it's the only way that
politicians can respond to jobs in a way
that deflects attention away from their
own inability to understand the jobs
problem in America it's much easier to
blame others than to take a look in the
mirror so my best guess is that while
the simple declaration of courtesy
methylation in and of itself just means
intensified negotiation between the
Chinese and their American counterparts
on the various economic teams that there
will be a ground swell of support in the
new Congress to push through one of
these currency bills that has been
battered around for the last seven years
started in 2005 where there would be
trade sanctions placed on China to
compensate for the degree of currency
manipulation and the Congress has come
up with a number 27 and a half percent
of the number no matter and I can tell
you where the number came up was it's a
total joke I was present at the creation
of his number but and wherever the
wherever the Chinese currency is
relative the dollar even though it's
risen thirty percent over the last seven
years it's always 27 a half percent
undervalue so the sanctions would be
under this legislation that could be
imposed would would be tariffs on all
Chinese exports in the United States of
instead of level 27 a half percent which
would be devastating of course for China
and for American consumers who buy
things it places like walmart the
largest retailer in the country in the
world and yeah I'm going on too long but
but what then happens is of course the
Chinese retaliated and what is never
said in these in these various debates
is the other side of the trade equation
is that china is our third largest
export market and by far most rapidly
growing so China puts trade sanctions of
a cockerel degree on our third largest
and most rapidly growing export market
we're having a few growth problems
America right now I think and this this
would be a fairly serious consequential
problem and you could take this sort of
tit-for-tat further there could be
further escalation by an angry US
Congress and and China's got the
ultimate trump card here they simply
stop buying Treasuries with dire
consequences for financial markets and
you know it's it's not a stretch to take
january twenty 2013 under the what i
think is
unlikely a presumption that Romney wins
and turn it into something that is a a
really dark tale Jeremy as you know
where China is in the midst of a
political transition of its own as China
looks here at the United States how does
how do you think China is iterative
expecting things to fall out and is
there a sense in which um if the
presidential election does end up
favoring Romney and he does label China
a currency manipulator how would the
Chinese react and what might some of
their concerns be well a couple points
there um first of all to follow up on
Steve's a point about job creation I
guess when you look at these bashing ads
it doesn't create some jobs i think they
call fact checkers and i've never seen
so many fact checkers after every ads
but outside of that it's really a very
limited in that sense and if you look
back at the us-china relationship it has
been exactly 40 years and we've gone
through eight presidents and if we look
back every year there seems to be some
bashing going on from Ronald Reagan and
all the way to the latest Barack Obama
against a george w bush so in many ways
it has become sort of a political
tradition in an election cycle but i
must note that in this cycle it has
become very harsh and it's beginning to
raise eyebrows and doubts in many ways
and when you cry wolf so many times at
some point somebody believes it and at
that point when the weather is the
public or the elites the leaders
thinking when it hardens i think it's
very difficult to
move beyond that that turning point so
it's a speculation in terms of how China
would react but it can play some what if
games and what if the new president
comes in and say on day one declare
China to be a currency manipulator
personally I think that's limiting the
United States to a very narrow corner
that has no option and if that happens i
think is probably going to take months
and years to untangle that and i think
it's likely that any trade war or
retaliation tit for tat would certainly
happened I don't think China would sit
down and say okay we are manipulators
and and follow up with that so I think
we need to consider the negatives and
these are D realistic negatives that
could happen and I think every
administration after all the rhetorics
they modified their positions and
becomes more realistic unfortunately
this cycle I'm not sure that it has that
flexibility it's painting we're painting
ourselves into a corner in some ways
when there are no options we may regret
what we said and then it would take a
long time to untangle something that has
taken 40 years to build up yeah just
just one follow-up appointment rightly
or wrongly I mean Romney has this great
reputation as a flip-flopper so let's
just assume that that he gets elected is
the first thing he does after the parade
does he do a flip flop I mean I ain't
just as well you know now that I'm in
the Oval Office it just sort of feels
different I mean he's going to have to
he says this every day he
can't back down he's in a corner so he's
going to do it under under the
assumption that he's elected and and I
think your question is is right we need
to explore the consequences and you know
I laid out some in a horrible sequence
of events and I hope that it's just a
bad dream and it doesn't happen but you
never know can we talk a little bit more
about what it would look like if China
retaliated most of this rhetoric seems
to be you know predicated on the
assumption that China trade simply hurts
American workers and businesses can we
talk about who in the United States
benefits from relations with China and
why are we hearing more about them look
I mean that this whole issue is really
you know good I think you know on a most
unfortunate fabrication to be blunt last
year we ran trade deficits the United
States with 98 countries 98 so take
China out by higher math at least 97 so
we have a multilateral trade deficit and
how do you how do you fix in China's the
biggest piece and we can get into the
hows and whys of that how do you fix a
multilateral trade deficit with putting
pressure on a bilateral currency it's
mathematically impossible it's like you
know say I'm holding a big water balloon
and you know I put pressure on one end
the Chinese piece in the water just goes
somewhere else and somewhere else will
be a combination of higher cost
producers that will still make things
that Americans need to buy look at a
higher price price of your goods that
you buy at Walmart will go up and the
real question jessica is why do we run a
multi
don't trade deficit what is it about our
country that forces us to run deficits
with 98 different countries and the
economic answer is is that we don't save
as a nation and when you don't save and
you want to grow you import surplus
savings from abroad you run massive
balance of payments deficits with the
world and behind a bounce payments
deficit is a multilateral trade
imbalance so if you want to you know get
rid of a deficit with with any country
you really need to put it in the context
of the broad constellation of all the
deficits we run and address the savings
problem there's no politician who has
the guts to go to the American people
and tell them to start saving in not one
speaking of savings and investment there
have been a number of controversies over
to annie's investment into the United
States Jeremy based on the committee of
100 survey and you're a broader
expertise how does a broader American
public feel about China including
Chinese investments which are growing
here in the United States it's really
interesting finding um this is a survey
that was conducted in the spring of this
year and one of these specific areas
that were asked would be about the
Chinese investment in the US and among
the public and the business elites as
well as the opinion elites I think an
overwhelming majority we're talking
about over eighty percent of the
business group and the opinion group
support increased US investment in China
and the United States in the public is
well over seventy percent muscle so in
that regard I think it's well received
in terms of the concept but I think at
the same time there were some concerns
about losing control of the economy and
I think that also is reflected in some
of the current government policies there
were some in terms of Chinese
investments whether it's in terms of
wind farms in Oregon
or other investments in the u.s. I think
outside of the purchase of the AMC the
movie chain there have been a few others
but not massive scale I think it's still
growing there's still some interest but
I think domestically I think the survey
also find some concerns in terms of
security in terms of losing control so a
sort of a dichotomy of yes we welcome
investments but at the same time how do
we maintain control so we'd like to
think that this sort of china bashing
has sort of you know passed already but
unfortunately just this week Romney
aired a new ad in Ohio talking about
jeep and closing down and moving to
china well Obama has countered saying
though your facts aren't quite right so
Erica was this a blunder on romney's
part even the OC chrysler CEO has
weighed in saying no no in fact you know
jeep is not unambiguously not moving
production to China or does the truth
not really matter in these negative ads
it's a really good question i think um
certainly we're actually working on a
piece right now about speaking of the
fact-checkers um the academic evidence
about fact-checking is actually quite
dismal um from a public opinions
perspective because the public tends to
remember the ad message more than the
remember that reporter correction of it
what we're interested in is the flip
side to what extent does fact-checking
influence campaign behavior and I
haven't looked specifically at China of
course but it's CN we've only looked so
far at 2008 but we're replicating it
again in 2012 is that the ads that are
shown to be false or actually more
likely to stay on the air then
oh no I'm not sure that's about the
Chinese that but i but I do that you
know this has been a prominent theme all
along it has it has dropped off a little
bit so if you compare our sort of top
issues in the presidential campaign in
September pro-romney ads of course this
includes on the outside interest groups
China was mentioned in almost thirty two
percent of all those earrings in
September whereas if you look at October
it's down to six point six percent of
earrings so the new China I don't and I
don't know specifically for that new
China ad how often it's run but you've
seen it come up on the Democratic side
sort of in the same time period so you
had very heavy Republican focus and then
sort of the pro-obama ads coming back in
response um so I do think it's still you
know and to play back to the to the
reason why it's being used i think it's
an easy scapegoat for both parties
because it is something that you can you
can reference without any backlash among
the public per se because no not
targeting anyone here purse that you
know i mean obviously there are
implications abroad but in terms of the
american public is a target that isn't
easy it's an easy reference that doesn't
cost you very much hmm that actually in
somewhat continue oh and turned yeah so
it leads right into a sort of a question
I have which are the speaking of
domestic consequences Jeremy can you say
a little bit about what sort of china
bashing might look like for the Asian
Americans living here in the united
states are there any sort of historical
precedence for this climate anti-chinese
sentiment and um just guy think only 30
years ago there was another Asian
country that was on the rise and Japan
was becoming the next biggest economy of
the world and the American public some
not all went to the streets and bash
American cars because there was the fear
that the Japan was
to take over the United States and then
there were media reports about Japan
buying Pebble Beach and you know half of
New York and some may not remember what
happened but the exactly 30 years ago
there was a young Chinese American by
the name of Vincent chin in detroit and
he was in a bar it was about a week
before his marriage and he was bashed to
death by a baseball bat by a father and
a son because he was mistaken to be
Japanese and there was so much hate that
Japanese were going to take over the
united states that the case lasted a
while and it costs a lot of emotions and
at one point the father and son were
released and it was one of those Rosa
Parks a case in Chinese American and
Asian American history if you go back
further you have the 1882 Chinese
Exclusion Act it was not friendly to
Chinese and was the only legislation in
the United States that is explicitly
against a race of people and then less
than 20 years ago there was accusation
about nuclear secrets being lost to
China and cosmic I guess controversies
in the National Laboratories and there
was that was a [ __ ] to internment
internal 120,000 japanese-americans so
we may not realize these 30 second one
minute bashing ads but they built little
by little to the American psyche and at
some point that's what i call a point of
no return
that something happens and then we have
to look at ourselves into the mirror and
say boy what happened and and yet
history historical facts after
historical facts but nobody really likes
to be called cheaters nobody really
wants to be called liars and you can be
called ones who can be caught twice but
at some point it's not going to hurt
just the Chinese in mainland China it
also hurts chinese americans in the
united states and there are some lessons
to be learned and hopefully we history
will not repeat itself in many ways and
i do get concerned when i see some of
these bashing that i'm not sure that
there are many in and I'm not picking
Iowa or any state but maybe not tell the
difference between a Japanese American
or Chinese American and at some point
that hate bills up that there is a point
of no return well just to reinforce that
point a little a little more even is
that you know I think the short-term
consequences to any particular
politician are so small that the
references are very easy but in the same
vein we also know that as elites tend to
lead public opinion when you have so
much rhetoric that's focused on China to
like how soon is it before you have
public opinion that is starting to
change and then what kind of influence
does that have been on the politicians
behavior so I think that that is the
longer term concern is is a big one you
know I also wanted to ask you to follow
up on Steve's comment but you know
Romney's basically become known as flip
flopper do politicians really feel that
they are accountable the things that
they say on the campaign trail not just
on China but more generally I I mean I
think they do I think one of the biggest
the biggest concerns is being painted as
a flip-flopper Romney's I mean handled
it perhaps as well as he could this
cycle but certainly it's not it's not
it's not an attractive odd adjective for
any politician and so to the extent that
they can avoid going on the record and
then coming back though they'll always
try to do it now on an issue that's you
know this big
who knows but um I mean I think what
they say does matter but certainly the
sort of connection between what they say
and what they actually do is an
imperfect one we just bore in on one
aspect of this the this purge or ative
term manipulation of a currency and the
point that Jeremy made it then that gets
taken into the realm of being labeled a
cheater and I really agree I think you
really stated your your points very
eloquently then the risk is when when
you when you listen to I find Erica's
stats on the frequency of the focus on
China on both sides of the the campaign
you know fascinating but very alarming
and but there's this point of no return
because you're you're building a
powerful impression and the impression
doesn't vanish the impression will
endure in the psyche of the American
people and we can see where that
impression is taken as to some pretty
dark places you just recited so
manipulation the Chinese currency was
pegged in other words fixed to the US
dollar through July of 2005 and it's not
uncommon for a developing economy to
anchor its currency to the world's
reserve currency as they're grappling
with development of their financial
system and their economy there was
pressure from China's trading partners
the United States Europe but also other
Asians to relax the
peg and given the trade surplus that was
building up in China there was a general
real realization that the currency was
too low and that this needed to rise and
so the Chinese embarked on what was then
called and has since been called a
managed float they would guide the
currency upward which is the right
direction no one knows what the exact
equilibrium level is and the currency
has risen since july of two thousand
five thirty percent against the dollar
actually thirty-two percent against the
dollar if you check it as a couple of
days ago and about thirty percent
against a broad basket of all the
currencies that China trades with now if
trying to just let it go it would have
gone up high so the difference between
where the market want to take it and
where it went is called manipulation and
I think again that sends a horrible
message because it imputes a the motives
of a cheater that is directed at
victimizing other people for the action
Jeremy also raised you know the the
issue of Japan in the late 1980s not
only did we bash Japan but we put Japan
through the same exact drill that we're
putting China through now in the
currency and in September of 1985 the
then g5 the group of the most powerful
industrial countries in the world got
Japan in the quarter in The Plaza Hotel
in New York and got Japan to agree to
the so-called Plaza court which forced
an instant high rapid appreciation of
the yen and the Japanese did it and that
set in motion a series of horrific
policy blunders that
that many of our getting clean myself
have now put japan mired in two lost
decades and Counting so the Chinese have
study the lessons of Japan very
carefully and they have agreed to
revalue their currency but not all at
once but gradually and some might call
that prudence or you could even go
further and call it wisdom because
you've learned from the mistakes of
others and yet you know we call it
manipulation the currency has gone up
plane the China's balance of payments
surplus with the world has shrunk
dramatically and you know as a peak of
like ten percent of GDP it's down to two
and a quarter percent right now it's
trade balance is shrunk dramatically the
currency will continue to rise and and
to continue to pound the table with the
sort of almost Byzantine perceptions of
the menace of Red China behind it is is
I think it's it's politically expedient
but for the eloquent points that you
just made it's very disturbing in so far
as what it says about that the character
of our nation and that really troubles
me we've talked a lot about this
political rhetoric and they're kind of
the shoe banging and I wanted to ask one
more question Jeremy of you before I
open it up to the audience for open
questions which is you know aside from
all this political grandstanding there's
a study you know set of negotiations
that go on behind you know closed doors
and sort of the normal course of
diplomacy and when you are at the
Department of Agriculture I noticed you
helped negotiate the end of a Chinese
ban on US wheat exports so I want to ask
you what is it like to negotiate with
the Chinese and is this a more
appropriate manner in which we should
settle our trade disputes and at what
point does the US government decide that
private channels are no
sufficient we need to go to the WTO and
file this publicly that's an excellent
question I guess the word that brings to
my mind would be patience and what
Jessica referred to was at one time the
US and China had a wheat dispute and
China buys weed from the US and yet
there was an embargo against the Pacific
Northwest wheat claiming that there is a
certain fungus that would wipe out wheat
production in China entirely and so it
was one of the typical trade issues back
in the 90s and so between the two
countries a more scientific approach was
used and guess what it took 10 years and
from the beginning of identifying the
spores of something called smut fungus
all the way to how the tiny microscopic
school spores can get on tons of wheat
that can go to China and be detected so
that it will not grow in China that
would wipe out the week production and
at least that's a rhetoric between the
two countries at that point and and I
think deep down between the two sides
they knew that it was rhetoric and so
both sides were serious and I got a call
on New Year's Eve 1990 basically the
Agriculture Department had conducted a
joint study with the Chinese scientists
and trying to decide on the microscopic
spores and they collected a lot of data
and on New Year's Eve they said now what
do we do with the data and that started
a 10-year project for me and ultimately
it was through negotiations and it was
difficult once I was saying
it has health impact and production
impact the NSI say basically is
manipulation and trying to lower price
of wheat but eventually the premier of
China came 1999 and signed an agreement
so patience and science and knowledge
can help to resolve the differences and
there was no World Trade Organization at
that point so the two countries were
willing to sit down and look at the
problems and avoid the cold war rhetoric
and basically trying to address the
issues and ten years later there was a
solution and I wonder with the World
Trade Organization now and there will be
issues and no doubt they'll continue be
trade issues but I think they all can be
resolved and given the last 40 years of
development between the two countries I
think it has become pretty apparent that
the two sides really want to broad the
relationship and therefore better
communications and collaboration can
help to resolve some of the issues thank
you so much well thank you all for your
attention I would like to now open the
floor to any questions you want to ask
if you'll please raise your hand and one
of this our helpers will pass the mic
here um it's been stated by the u.s.
that it's moving its center of gravity
can we identify oh yeah I'm Gus Ranas
Economics Department the US is shifting
its strategy from Europe to Asia and it
made certain moves Australia and so on
now my question is the US has a treaty
with japan it doesn't have a treaty with
China and all these disputes going on to
the islands that Japan and China arguing
about there's some argument the Chinese
have made it seems to me the u.s. is
supporting Japan how serious is this in
the China
I in terms of relations I think it's
very serious myself and to look at the
gravity of the matter you really have to
look at the history of China for the
last 200 years and during the last 200
years territories was a big dispute and
and you at the china and japan for the
several wars and they were about metal
terrorism in many ways territorial
rights in many ways and the Second World
War was a very bitter battle between
China and Japan and I think some have
described these dell you or the Senkaku
Islands to be several rocks in the
middle of the ocean but i think it's
taken very seriously by the people in
both the peoples of a japan and china in
in that regard and i do think that at
this point a small trigger can in fact
cause conflicts and in many ways it
seems like the joint defense treaty with
the japan is something that may
willingly or unwillingly draw the u.s.
into the conflict and i do wonder myself
personally that a treaty that was
established in 1960 during the peak of
the Cold War when China was quote on the
other side is it still applicable 50
years later in a repeating situation
that the u.s. is taking whether the
partnership or the Alliance should also
be recalibrated that's a personal view
but it seems like if
the current caller course is not managed
well from my perspective I think it can
be very serious and can lead to in fact
a military conflict between jerk you are
suing are definitely between Japan and
China and the US maybe unwillingly drawn
into it because of the joint defense
treaty door okay um my name's thorsten
fries on the East Asian Studies student
my question is that given the recent
blocking of Chinese investment in
windmills and the I think can
congressional investigation into whether
the huawei communication company is
capable of you know covert spy
operations against the US public to what
extent the kid in this environment to
what extent does it really matter who
the president is because I mean we have
these issues of animosity already taking
place you know that's a fair point both
the President and governor romney are I
mean again Erica gave me the numbers
there they're both focused on sort of a
china bashing strategy as as part of
their political efforts in especially in
these final weeks and days of the
campaign and I think that that unless
there's a dramatic change in the
domestic environment in the united
states that post-election will continue
to have a lot of focus on china as the
lightning rod that the cause the easy to
sell and market source of the problem
that's bearing down on the economy this
is not you know I don't want to
whitewash China there's a lot of issues
in China and some of the cyber terrorism
that originates in China I mean tho
those are those are major issues that
need to be addressed and whether that
it's it's a pro correct to single out
huawei or ZTE which is another company
that gets mentioned there as the source
of this you know it's fine to
investigate that and the American public
has a right to know and understand and
to take actions if in fact there are
legitimate violations that have occurred
but I think we've got to be really
careful post-election that we don't give
much broader footprint to the the
political sentiment that has really been
allowed I think to get out of hand one
of the guys I come across and he's been
invited to Yale conferences that I have
participated in and I recently I agreed
to do a debate I have no idea why I did
this but but Huffington Post now has a
video
for more they they they have debates on
various topical issue so they had a
debate on us-china and they invited me
and a couple of other people and then
they invited this fear monger by the
name of Peter Navarro who is a professor
at the University of California San
Diego really yeah check them out it's my
alma mater so right here then you
definitely gotta check him out hey what
he's written a book and has produced a
movie called death by China and it is it
is really just filled with you know it's
got your flags and you know babies dying
and all sorts of things that the plate
of the emotions of anybody it's it's a
pure a charade there's not one shred of
truth and so I and they had the audacity
during the so-called debate to actually
play the trailer to the movie and so I
I'm sitting there you know in my office
you know few blocks away on skype you
know I'm making you know hand gestures
and after the trailer I said look I'm
going to disconnect from this debate
because I never agreed to participate
under the you know the grounds that this
is going to be a promotion to you know a
film that is spews forth you know this
fear mongering vindictive diatribe
against you know another nation I you
know again go back to Jeremy's point you
know the point of no return is something
we need to look yet we need to look
inside of ourselves and see this is what
we want to stand for
nation so your point on doesn't matter I
think it ultimately does matter because
the next president whether it's the
incumbent or the Challenger in early
January of next year there's going to be
a test of his character can he pull back
the rhetoric that he and then they both
died they've done it differently but
they're both using China is a lightning
rod to play on the insecurities and the
understandable pain and hardship of
American workers and their families but
can they do they have the strength
within them to to really pull back and
and I don't know I honestly don't know I
hope they do I want you know but I don't
know my name is Victoria Bueller I'm a
senior in yale college and it seems
clear that the US should not label china
as a currency manipulator both because
of the immediate threat of retaliatory
talia Tory sanctions but then this
larger danger that China might play the
trump card however if the US doesn't
engage with China over the currency
issue now it's clear that as China's
power grows there will be areas in which
the u.s. does need to engage with China
and not sound like I'm interested in
manipulation but areas in which the US
needs to extract concessions from China
so given this are there any sort of
hidden leverage points the u.s. can
drawn to increase its bargaining power
as opposed like in opposition to China
and if we don't currently have a trump
card should we be thinking about
developing one
ah particular first and this I think
part of the issues that has developed is
really trade between the two countries
and both import and export have grown
over the years except that our export
has not caught up with our import so if
we become more savvy I think if we can
reduce the barriers I'm pretty confident
and I'm pretty optimistic that the u.s.
can improve its performance on exports
and narrow the trade deficit but at this
point you do have to wonder is the
government helping in terms of the
American company selling to to China the
committee of 100 survey seem to indicate
that the public seemed to point at US
policies as a barrier to that with about
seventy percent of the respondents
indicating that the u.s. policy may be
creating some of those barriers through
policies or bureaucracy so it seems to
me that in one area that can help to
relieve some tension is our export to
keep up with the invoice at least that's
one area that I can think of but by
night look it's a great question it
really is and you know it's it's it's a
two-way story
there's a you know we push hard on China
for variety of different motives some of
which are fair and some of which are
really why the mark and and China pushes
back on us reflecting their own
constellation of motives we need China
we need China to buy our debt because we
don't save we need the China is an
offshore production platform to enable
American consumers to stretch stagnant
wages over a larger market basket China
needs us China needs us for the fuel of
what is still an export-led economy and
they need us for their transition I mean
Victoria's in my class so she knows I
talk a lot about the transition of China
to a different type of an economy
consumer-led as opposed to an export and
investment let economy and China doesn't
really have a clue as to what a
consumer-led culture is all about and
unfortunately that's you know something
we know a lot about we've been taking
the model excess but but there's a lot
that is not programmed in the DNA of the
Chinese producer model that bears on
what they need to know and build in
terms of creating a consumer culture and
there's a there's a lot that they can
rely on us and that we can offer them in
return that is mutually advantageous you
know the two countries are from an
economic point of view very dependent on
one another to the point where you could
even argue that they'd gotten into this
rather delicate zone of codependence
which is it there any psychologist in
the room
you can you can speak more eloquently
than I can on this but that's not a very
healthy and stable relationship if you
don't require both participants in a
codependent relationship to engage in a
deep psychological therapy some some
have called it mutually assured
financial destruction that's what's over
our heads but it also makes it perhaps
difficult for China to use this
so-called trump card which actually
makes me a little bit less pessimistic
about this rhetoric on economic issues
getting too far out of hand i'm much
more pessimistic or concerned about some
of the territorial disputes in the
region and the prospect of the military
conflict in which the u.s. might be
drawn there's one point about the
intellectual property rights that i
don't think we have touch upon but i
think that's an area that both countries
can also work on and i think china has
been accused and i think rightly so
about the need to respect intellectual
property rights and i do believe that I
I think I had visited China for the
first time about 30 years ago compared
to today there has been tremendous
progress make in that area but I think
it still needs a lot more to work on and
I think China is facing its own problem
now in the court system when it deals
with IPRs the intellectual rights
property rights cases now more than half
of them internal Chinese issues rather
than dealing with the foreign countries
at this time so it's a matter of growth
into that area and I think overall IPR
is is a hot topic and I think it can
also produce a lot of progress if the
two countries collaborate on it the
gentleman in the back has been waiting
patiently yeah hi my name is dr. Jason
leo I'm the current executive board
member of the National Organization for
Chinese American who have a headquarter
in watching the
see myself has actually pretty involved
with this you know china-us things I was
the first one to make the Westies brick
through trees were set establish the
Shanghai Bell Telephone manufacturing
blocking the progress made but my
concern is really does because this is a
really very high impact high-stake game
geopolitical and the trade and financial
issue unfortunately the the current
should hurt American democratic process
have the requirement to get a vote how
do you get vote you have to emotionalize
the debate that's a reality and even
though I'm a chinese-american can use
the morphing really is a very small
minority here they're definitely have
consequences but my consciousness is not
on the individual to the chinese
american IM american but is really to
the future of America itself how could
we elevate enlighten the American public
to a higher level of sophistication
dealing with the globalization can I
included and Yale University self has
been cultivated many of the American
leaders in the past I want to found the
audience I wanted really so color
mainframe armor a mainstream Americans
how could we American to to maintain
this the Democratic are married yet to
produce a system to seriously
responsibly and prudently dealing with
those many challenging
in the future I think the American
election process cell has to be examined
by the future occur in the future leader
I want your comment and also the
students inputs thank you thank you and
maybe Erika you could speak a little bit
too money in politics and this is not
just specific to China but the overall
tenor and level of discourse in American
politics and on television yeah I mean I
think one of the one of the first things
so you know I teach up at Wesleyan
University just right up the road and I
would say the same thing to students
here at Yale as I say to my my students
at Wesleyan is I love having you in
class you're intellectually curious and
that's one of the reasons I love having
you here but you are absolutely not the
average American and that you have to
start with that assumption if you want
to really understand public opinion and
political behavior in American politics
because the Advocate average American is
it's not so much I mean in the public
opinion literature there was a lot of
debate over sort of the the in
competence of the American public and I
think that gives the american public a
little too little credit um it I don't
think it's that people are say stupid
and that is it that is a common critique
I I think people are are sophisticated
enough to get it but they don't pay
attention to politics they're busy um
and that's the way I describe it is that
the average American is busy they've got
their job that got their kids they've
got you know the other things that are
going on in their lives and they don't
you know the sort of especially the key
persuadable public which is really what
we're talking about here right we've got
a million add earrings in the
presidential race in fewer markets than
there ever have been so it's a fewer
amount of citizens are actually seeing
that onslaught and they're not intended
for even the majority of the people that
are in those markets because there's
nothing that Obama or Romney can say to
convince the other sighs partisan so
what we're really talking about is that
very small segment of persuadable border
voters in the key battleground markets
that will make a difference for the
electoral
so it's tough I think it's very tough um
but I do think you know the average
American also gets it right even if I
don't pay a lot of attention to politics
one of the reasons you see so many
political ads on television because
that's one of the primary ways that the
campaign's actually talked to those
voters because those voters aren't right
listening to the news they aren't they
don't read the papers they're not
political junkies like I am you know and
read ten ten you know ten things before
i even had breakfast in the morning um
and and so that's the primary way that
they talked to these people but the but
you know citizens don't how to get
hungry yes too much coffee super I
suppose but but you know I think too
that you know citizens don't necessarily
have to pay attention to politics to
understand some things you know when
they go to the to the gas pump and fill
up their tank and when they talk to
their neighbor next door and when they
you know sit around the water cooler at
work you know they get some cues about
how the state of the economy is and
china isn't I think very far afield from
what they what you know what their cues
are and that is one of the reasons I
think why it's being used so so well I'm
stop blathering on but I do it's a great
question and I do you know I think we
all would wish that the American public
was more sophisticated and paid more
attention but it's not the world we live
in unfortunately and I and I think to
really understand at least the political
side and the political game and the
reason why you're seeing what you see is
you have to start with that assumption
it's not it's not necessarily that the
politicians are I mean the politicians
do pander but one of the reasons they do
that is because of the dynamics of of
the public but what he was also asking
erica's is if we if there was a strong
feeling that that the political system
was really producing potentially
damaging results how how might we change
it is there a
a process by which we could actually
contemplate altering the ground rules of
debate term limits campaign finance
reform or there're a number of things
that should be at you know brought into
the discussion more actively want to
think is so in each one of those and
this is just you know political science
tends to be the hold on calm down it's
about it's gonna be okay type of a hub
mode is that you know the problem with
term limits is that you actually do want
people who know what they're doing so to
speak there's a but big in a learning
curve you think these guys know what
they're doing okay sis know some cases
no but you know in campaign finance
we've been trying to sort of close the
loopholes in money in politics for a
very long time and every sort of sort of
at every turn you see you find the
loopholes keep getting bigger and wider
and you know the vicar of the bipartisan
campaign reform act was supposed to
close the soft money loophole for
parties and what we ended up was a
transfer from party spending to interest
group spending we can talk about whether
or not that's that's a good on the
upside the positive of all this campaign
spending is that we know that citizens
have more meaningful things to say about
the candidates and despite all the anger
and negativity on the airwaves those
things actually there's evidence that
suggests that that actually does create
information seeking and people who don't
necessarily pay attention so if there's
something good to be said about that it
is that the people who don't necessarily
pay attention if they're exposed to some
fear through the airwaves they actually
are more likely to go out and seek
additional information now what they're
getting in that additional information
is of course the key question but um
this may explain why Chrysler got so
many calls saying you know what you're
moving Jeep to China and then Christ i
cain't say no no
we're staying right here in fact we're
increasing her operations right yeah
yeah absolutely Jessica Mary offers
small story here one of my I'm a great
admirer of a great American Norman
Mineta and some of you may have heard of
him and he was one of the hundred twenty
thousand Japanese Americans who were
interned during the Second World War he
his family lost all the properties and
if there is one who should be really mad
at this country he should be one of them
and yet I i would like to quote him and
and basically he said America is great
not because it's perfect but because it
can correct it sells along the way so he
rose to be one of the mayors of san jose
and and one of the congressmen and
eventually became the first Asian
American Secretary of Commerce in both
administration's democratic as well as a
Republican administration also in the
Department of Transportation so his
story was very inspiring to me and I
have a very optimistic outlook in that
regard and I think no matter how small
the percentage of Chinese Americans
would be or the Asian Americans would be
the organization of Chinese American is
a great organization it's a grassroots
organization I participate actively in
it and it plays a big role and and play
a very optimistic role that we're very
happy that we have a role to play and we
participate actively in the American
system be a part of the American society
and as a member of the committee of 100
each one of us also dedicate ourselves
and that is how to further the Chinese
American contribution to the American
Society that's our ideal that's our
passion thank you
another question from the audience yes
please go ahead in the middle you yes
please yes I'm Emily Tom I am a
international investment banker in the
last 20 years I basically spent a month
in China and a month in the u.s. so I
commute and so I had to get both ends in
terms of grief and in terms of joy and
so the what you said I don't think that
does anything new that nobody here have
that I never heard before yes through
the conversations and your presentation
Jeremy you did mention that we need
patience we need better communications
we need this and that and but basically
seems like it kind of referred to
somebody else my question is how can
each one of us here in this room do
something about it such that this can be
changed for the better and I like to
hear the wisdom of all four of you
from my perspective I have happily
retired from the federal government but
I also remain very active both in terms
of working with government employees
working with the community organizations
and I'll be taking off and visiting
China next month next week actually and
I'm engaged in one project some of you
may have heard of and that is in the
Internet age there is a big data yeah
and big data is something that can help
open up government make it more
transparent and I'm hopeful that China
and the US will follow through with that
and and and that is built these smart
countries build these smart cities and I
think the World Bank and the State
Council of China had released a report
earlier this year it's China in 2030
that would be a modern harmonious
high-income creative country and it may
be very idealistic but once upon a time
an American president also said you know
what in 10 years we're going to the moon
and we need that kind of optimism and
everyone has a role to play and I'm very
active in the committee of 100 and we
believe in three things one is education
the education exchange between the two
countries would be vitally important I
think you said you mentioned
you spent one month in China and one
month in the US the fact is that only 1%
of Chinese have visited the US and maybe
six or seven percent of the Americans
have visited China so if everyone has a
chance to do that I think it would
greatly promote the understanding of the
two sides second area I thing is in
terms of leadership development and our
the committee of 100 has been very
active in terms of grooming leaders of
both sides in the United States and in
China looking for visionary idealistic
individuals of both countries that can
be the future leaders one way or another
that can see the value and promote the
collaboration between the two countries
and thirdly we're very active in public
diplomacy so between the leaders of both
sides we try to meet visit them and
essentially built bridges so everyone
has a role to play and it's a matter of
how you view at how you see it and I
mentioned earlier about participating in
American society and that's also an
extremely valuable role if anything in
my retirement I don't have enough time
to do all the activities but I wish I
would and then I think individually I
think everybody can make time to engage
in some activities that can be rewarding
and in fact benefit people that you may
not know but in the long run for bigger
mass of people that you didn't realize
like Jeremy I'm also you know a big
proponent of people-to-people education
when I was an undergraduate I started an
organization to bring student leaders
from both sides together to become
friends but you know as Erica pointed
out the people who select into these
programs already we're sort of preaching
to the choir and so the real challenge
is reaching people who aren't paying
attention
and who might sort of in a very neat
jerk fashion or react badly to something
they don't know very much about I mean
I'm very encouraged by the fact that
more and more students across the
country or learning Chinese at a very
very early age it's hard to imagine them
seeing China as something scary and
foreign when they about the ability to
read you know this the novels or the
short stories or they even the kids
books from the very you know from the
very beginning of their education but
how do we get there you know how do we
get 30 years down the road where many
American many more Americans already
read and speak Chinese or an equivalent
or even larger numbers of Chinese speak
and ring it in and contribute to
American discussions I that's how do we
get from here to there is I think the
question in its interim and
fear-mongering still really works you
know that that's that transition both
you know in this sense but also in the
military and other sorts of you know
aggregate power this transition period
is really the what has me worried yeah I
would just add one it's sort of easy to
for us to say well you know these are
politicians and they're playing
election-year games and there there's a
whole big population of non politicians
who are really truth-seeking and are
more honest with the people they they
come across every day I wish that were
the case with respect to China I have
over the years maybe over the last 10
years I have personally testified in
front of the US Congress on us-china
trade issues or other types of China
related issues no 12 15 times and when
you testify you're using on a panel four
or five people like this and you
you're-you're chosen to represent your
institution but there are other
academics or business people and other
so-called defense experts there are not
all non politicians
and yet I find that more often than not
and I would say by a margin of two to
one they and these are leading thought
leaders heads of very well-known think
tanks academics from institutions on a
level like this they will present views
that are prejudicial and biased and not
not accurate from my point of view I
found in you know my life is her like
yours I did 30 years of investment
banking the last five years I was going
back and forth between Asia and the US
and and yet still doing some of this
participating actively in the debate in
this country and I personally got sick
of having my own credibility as an
expert witness draw and drawn into
question because I was a senior
executive for a Wall Street bank who had
a big business in China said well he's
just trying to you know get business
with the Chinese and that was the
furthest thing from my truth when when
the truth when I would actually honestly
present my views in the United States
Congress so I welcome the opportunity to
come to a place like Yale to make
certain that there's a debate I I don't
claim that you know to be right but I
have a point of view and I'm more than
willing to engage others in this
institution and to participate in the
educational process of this great
University to make sure that the
students get a broad spectrum of
exposure to debate on issues like like
this so it's hard to say that one person
can move the needle but if we all say
that then you know the needle doesn't
move and
and if enough people get involved I
think you can you can make a difference
we have time for just one more question
here um sorry oh wait let's make it to
you keep it quickly so um my name is
Angelo from the school of Forestry and
environmental study and we talked a lot
about the bash in China mentality in the
political campaign here so I'm curious
about since China is also going through
is once in a decade top leadership
transition do you guys see a possibility
of a strong political discourse of
bashing us a in China as sort of a reply
to the bash in China USA thanks I'll
take this inside work on Chinese
nationalism although everybody else has
also welcome to comment unfortunately I
don't think that there's any need for
China to react to this latest round the
America bashing in China has a longer
history and you know dates at least back
to nineteen ninety nine when the United
States in a NATO airstrike accidentally
bombed the Chinese embassy in Yugoslavia
as their large anti-american
demonstrations at the time although when
two years later there was a collision
between a Chinese fighter jet and a u.s.
spy plane over Hainan the demonstrations
weren't allowed so it's not that
anti-americanism us say bashing is out
of control but you know the kinds of
rhetoric that we're seeing here only
sort of adds fuel to the fire and
there's a lot of apprehension not
necessarily about the rhetoric but
simply the fact of you as policies in
the region and so there's sometimes I
think we have a tendency I mean it's
it's scary and I'm concerned that's
boxing in US politicians here at home
but there are real policies underlying
regardless of who becomes president that
are of grave concern to Chinese and so a
very influential commentator and
professor said that he would actually
prefer a Romney presidency not because
Romney would necessarily be more
friendly to China but at least there
wouldn't be this illusion that China was
somehow that the u.s. was somehow
sympathetic and to China's rise so it's
only through that lens of there's
embedded suspicion
artless that perhaps the rhetoric and
think it's added on so an interest of
time I'll go to our last question and
please okay I'm I'm Bethany Allen I'm a
master's student in East Asian Studies
and I wanted to a comment and ask a
question about what Professor Fowler had
brought up about education and how it
occasionally nishat is are so important
it was you who said that wasn't it
that's prolly education educate well I
agree I'm not like teaching about it up
and I'm and can't quite a member who um
but I really feel strongly about that
that the more American students who have
the opportunity to spend time in China I
will really help relations between the
two countries however I feel concerned
because I so I worked in China for a
couple of years in a study abroad
program and that was through and the CCC
you which is a consortium of a little
over a hundred small liberal arts
colleges and universities and
unfortunately the trend and I I'm not
sure if that is simply these schools our
or if it's merely because of the economy
the way it is but a lot of these schools
are pulling funding or creating a lot of
barriers for their own students to
participate in this particular study
abroad program and I really believe that
measures such as you know the new
100,000 strong initiative are really
going to do a lot purpose but I really
hope that not just really great
university or really you know very well
funded and well known and prestigious
universities like yell and others
continue to pour money into this but
that very middle-ranking schools across
the country even community colleges are
able to have more more study abroad
funding more sony abroad programs more
chinese language courses and do you
think that that is a trend that that
that can be a trend or that that will
happen and if or is there more funding
going to that or doesn't you know about
that thank you perhaps Jeremy could
speak to this I I don't think I can
really speak on
the funding side but I'd certainly echo
the sentiment that you expressed Abby
and on a downer note here foot from my
name is Abby new man I'm executive
director of the Council on East Asian
Studies and thank you all for coming
tonight just from a perspective here
from the council we are this this actual
program was supported with today with
funding from the US Department of
Education title six grant that actually
calls Yale and many other institutions
across across America a national
resource center for the study of east
asian languages and cultures our fund of
the the reality that we are faced with
and part of this is just I think the
financial downturn that the that really
the global economy is suffering that
funding has been cut and the grants that
we've applied for and the the true
status and what is going to happen with
the us to provide Department of
Education which funds so many different
opportunities for cultural exchange the
study of foreign languages not just
Chinese but I'm across a broad spectrum
that it's of great national interest
that that that students are learning for
at all ages starting you know from K
through 16 all the way up the reality is
that funding is cut the US government
has has a very important role and it's I
think we're at a very important
crossroads on many different levels with
the election what it what is going to
happen with those funding sources to
help the smaller schools that cannot
only teach the languages but also have
these exchanges and a variety of
programs that are national interests and
of strategic interests so we're
experiencing ourselves here at Yale for
federal funding that and many other
institutions that have have had funding
cuts I don't want to end on a really
different note but it is it's a reality
that
going on because it's a call to action
so very much thank you all for joining
us here and please join me in giving a
big honour hand too